cogli lo colgo con uno strano urlo il
belfiore svanisce ma poverino dei petali
bianchi sono sparsi per terra prendi è
tutto petali di fiore grazie che
cattiverie scusa castro non devo farlo
ragazze posso prendere le ho sentite ho
sentito le sue urla lo sentite a
casarini la nostra promessa ecco a te e
dotto polvere bianca grazie ma io non
faccio uso di queste cose dovevate darle
alla polacco fa uso di co di polveri
ciao stregato sparisce ogni tre secondi
colta la comunque astràgali la strega
non è cattiva secondo me poi vabbè ho
trovato di polvere bianca tieni usa
pippa la persona afferra le sbarre ei
dammela silenzi tutti calmi perché non è
che ci hai messo la polvere bianca tra
le sbarre tieni la persona prende
velocemente la polvere
aspetta un attimo io non ho una senza
quella senza quella non posso neanche
usarla a voi sarebbe poi così no per
tirare
old style lagambiente cadute i cardini
sulla porta sembrano rotti aprì a
particina hai aperto la particina
qualcosa di invisibile è saltato fuori
speriamo che ve l'ha nascosta nel buio
spostare buio che
[Musica]
vela le piante si sono sono state
mangiate da qualcosa all'uccello a rega
si è mangiato le piante andiamo no
quando su quando non c'è la musica e
l'odio ve lo giuro l'odio
l'acqua è sigillata dai teschi una
vecchia pentola metti la mano non fare
niente non fare niente che lo salva la
partita ma ripensandoci è meno
pericoloso infilare la mano qua quindi
infilavano c'è un teschio dentro grazie
a dio è tutto un teschio bene né oltre
ne manca ne mancano manca uno ne servono
4 in totale niente aveva anche un
teschio regalo in una volta uno tra
tutti quelli che ho trovato ne manca
ancora uno è ancora un teschio non so
dove prenderlo non ho la più pallida
idea
avremmo tolto tutto grazie uccello
quindi posso andare anche avanti scusa
quindi posso andare anche suo e non
avevo capito sta roba teschio grazie no
no al timer noè i timer non regga porca
vacca datemi un teschio teschio prende
una foto presa da se non lo vedo come
viene fuori faillace così ho mancato
pure sono uscita ma un gioco dove devi
solo muoverti su riuscita ma anche alla
porta cava cà prende una cosa ho preso
veloce via via via 54
veloce barca vacca fa chi è chi se ne
frega tanto il teschio cielo credo a
sinistra poi non sono sicuro sia giusto
è sta roba perché boh
ok hai sentito e l'acqua scorrere bene
andiamo avanti non ho veramente non so
se ho fatto giusto per si ricava non è
vero da emiliano poi entra in una porta
minuscola non userà no non mi fa perché
direi questo cielo fare il giro dei
teschi pure porca vacca again the sky
stai ferma tuma data arriva uno schiaffo
che denti coppo c'è veramente non ha
idea di salvare salva salva arca vacca
va beh tutto questo che succeda l'acqua
di sopra del baratro all e quindi si sta
roba
girino mio padre è morto ma no al povero
ma perché mio padre è stato mangiato da
un serpente manova poverini tula jucci
il rospo ed altro episodio dal padre non
è vero il karma regala la vendetta è un
piatto che va servito con i girini
questi erano i figli del parco ma come
fanno a sapere che le uniche l'ho ucciso
io il padre ma i piani nella bottiglia
no peccato velocità ci ho provato ai
petali nella bottiglia mese petali una
bottiglia che meno forti ma c'è forse
qualcosa sta bottiglia sia ora in fila
che ha riempito la bottiglia ma ci
stanno i petali la bottiglia iniziato a
emettere luce a prefetto adesso posso
entrare nella stanza quella da bojano
alla fine i girini non servono a niente
e robots di armi dalla mia dal mio
obiettivo bene se entra quando voi
parlate fate le pettegole beh
sicuramente non è abbastanza tranquilla
io la madonna che è successo aiuto
guarda non so se sicuro guardare sotto
tutti i tavoli e c'è un piccolo orologio
da polso prendi ma perché
non puoi liberarti per qualche strano
motivo no ho solo preso un orologio e
monte devi incazzati pare che deve
succede ogni volta qualcosa di strano
porca eva andiamo di sotto o tutto
orologio da polso te lo tieni tu
salve devo faccio ok poi gara molto
gentili grazie però il suo posso andare
perfetto saleh state al vostro posto non
è difficile non inglobare da dietro non
micro m'incazzo throw giuro o c'è
qualcosa in unica se ti prendi una pipa
di giada l'aifo tuta già dalla viva le
mani a posto
sto parlando ok
[Musica]
pian piano però c'è e va bene ma dolce
all'ansia
[Musica]
dai fatto lungo non è vero
sono uscito e ho tenuto premuto il tasto
suo e non lo sapevo tutto il tasco
perché ho detto mi chiami accordo che la
porterà solo salute nel prodotto su
perfetto che ho trovato una pipa in
tutto questo una pipa non so cosa mi
serve ma ho una pipa doveva veramente
pippare il tizio ora in cella kasami
chiudi il libro pirla c'è veramente dove
dalla pip al tizio lancia la pipa di
giada la persona prende la pippa ha sì
questa è mia e mi è la persona sbagliata
come svanisce nella cella senti qualcuno
lasciare la tra cella battito 5 zio apri
[Musica]
andata bene è fatto shopping che oggi
carpet in edipo a da leggere lasciale
sanguinare maglie le scarpe
[Musica]
basta battere 5 ho visto una notizia
descritto non metti con le scarpe in
attimo devo uscire anzi a proposito non
è che devo ammettere le preture passare
il pavimento mettere mentre indossa
scarpe pezzi di merda ma un [ __ ]
marin baumann a un [ __ ] malissimo
non pensavo mai che mettendo oggi voglio
credere dai registrarne hanno anche un
[ __ ] hanno detto non metti le scarpe
maledetti delitti e strappare me lo
ricordo è lei mese lei mese nell'acqua
[Musica]
laureys cup il comitato me ne esco con
delle robe incredibili e non so come
lavando via il sangue le scarpe
diventano trasparenti aiuto delle scarpe
di vetro aral era sangue quello i girini
i morti civili morti galleggiano
nell'acqua poverino oh ma è stato pure
loro ammazzato po sterminato la famiglia
o sterminato padre figli io vi giuro non
ci arriva un età decente nella mia vita
muoio di infarto primato kakà se n'è
andato mi chiama per un millesimo di
secondo ce l'ho fatta tra l'altro ok
posso o le scarpe e trasparenti interior
esposto metterle ora puoi camminare sul
veleno auto e in automatico quindi passo
passo di qua ok si è veloce
porca fatto che non c'è tempo ma dollari
ma come era allora l'impossibile ma non
ce la farò mai in tempo è possibile ma
non ce la farò mai ma nei mille anni ce
la farò mai
ma devo andare dritto da girare non
andare dritto immagino lo pestata ho
fatto apposta chissenefrega sono mira
allenta le scatole sono fratturate ma va
bene così l'on
cosa credi che sia un amico perché non
dovresti o scopri che il gatto in alta
strega scommettete ieri la strega leggi
non lo ips perché mi ha salvata dalla
mia malattia
la pipa così l'ho fatta diventare mia
amica ma l'altra porta in tutto questo
posso tornare indietro a ok adesso posso
torno indietro chiesto a porta così sta
roba
una bambola senza testa prendi aiuto
bubble ok perfetto
posso solo andare avanti che bambola
senza te non so cosa serva ma va bene
quando c'era qualcosa nell'ombra l'ho
visto e vedo le cose in sto gioco chiedo
cose oscura vetrata si trova
c'è una bottiglietta sullo scaffale
prendi se eva morta la testa di una
bambola già ci par te la prendi ciò il
set completo ora kakà
cos'erano cos'erano quico occhi cos'è
nuova nomina mai
porca vacca garanzia vai salva non posso
salvare non c'è il capo è sparito non ho
idea di dove debba andare intanto
schiaccio cose e la madonna
ciao ragazze non sono morte come il
fiore giallo già sim pezzi tagliati ma
no l'orologio sta masticando a e
l'orologio che mastica al signore non
avevo visto va bene intanto su ca
l'orologio è caduto grazie a dio mentre
non ce l'ho sotto che non è colpa mia
ok sono impicca l'unico gioco dove puoi
vedere dell'erba impiccata [ __ ]
l'insalata questo da portatore indietro
proprio ancora più indietro
minchia ma chi c'era mai arrivata sta
roba
non ci ho mai pensato hai messo la
bambola sul pianista mi chiama chi se la
ricordava figura si aziona c'è un
passaggio grazie
c'è un buco scendi davvero non vedo
alternative scendi per forza è vivace e
sostanza sto andando dritto a si sta
roba
vieni nella mia stanza
ok se proprio devo posso ai sono tornati
in casa miglia che fiat ha un vaso di
rose ma ha tirato di tutto il web che
figata elevata la musica in tutto questo
è tanto quadro di fiori o gatto il cada
come morto il cadavere di un gattone è
morto il gatto lega ma veramente no non
è vero
scusa gatto e devo salvare posso salvare
partita lo stesso no e aprì a bordo è
permesso
sempre più vivace
[Musica]
una tazza rovescia un letto insanguinato
devo leggere il libro diario della
strega leggi la mia malattia stava per
uccidermi quindi ho preso il suo corpo
ho continuato a vivere nel suo corpo ti
sta bene vero perché siamo amiche mi ha
dato il suo porco perché siamo amiche
quindi oggi dovremo giocare uno tra poco
giusto viola ha violato io violare la
tizia che sto comando ragazza senza
gambe la madonna
posso salvare grazie a dio scappa grazie
bye bye bye bye veloce immediato
bicchiere brutta roba
porca vacca che è parte ansiolitica che
questa stava andando anche bene perché
se non fosse che va beh dovrei sia per
la memoria la struttura della casa vai
dai ho affrontato teschi giganti
minchiate che sei senza gambe madonna no
no no un porca eva scusa forte porta
tratto tra la strada giusta al casinò
vai quanto fatta benestante bershka
vacca è sì ci ho fatto ciò va sul sito è
uscito perfetto devo salvare aperta
partita devo salvare
posso solo pregare prendi aiutato una
lettera la prima parti non entra per
tutta leggi cara viola scusami se ti ho
svegliata ieri c'è una vecchia leggenda
che dice di una strega che vive nella
foresta e rapisce i bambini che si
smarriscono lì la casa ha dato amica è
molto vicino alla foresta quindi ero
preoccupato
era preoccupato per te l'atomica si
chiama l vero non mi
non mi cosa non mi dispiace che acquista
la prima parte con l'avevo letto non mi
dispiace che tu vada a casa sua ma stai
lontana dalla foresta spero di rivederti
a casa presto parlando a questa è la
lettera completa figata quindi è povero
papà
torniamo da mio padre posso la via
bloccata nel cespuglio aspetta aspetta
che ciò la bottiglietta uccide le robe
da ex fi ga hoole e
[Musica]
mio padre
viola
ma poi i viola
sei tu viola sei sicuro ti sei fatta
male no papà o solo combattuto con
satana e altra gente peggio prove
grazie al cielo ma che bello
hai fatto molto tardi quindi piace
accade in tutta la foresta
sono felice che ti stia bene andiamo a
casa al riparo dalla pioggia no no no no
no dai
no dai vestiti tasso dai regala papa ci
posso spiegare a casa però ti spiego vai
via corri
accorrete no papà ti prego viola sta
indietro
bravo papà così cattivo da mamma che
quanto e cazzuto mio padre così si fa
testata in bocca sì però non stiamo a
guardare il cadavere è guardia via
cazzuto mio papà bravo bravo papà mamma
mia mamma mia così stiamo compressione
discuterà che bravi bra o minchia
incredibile guarda
[Musica]
grazie dio no mica finale bello bello
bello quando mai il gioco che finisce
bene che strano che una volta ogni tanto
c'è stata valvola di sfogo bella
sono proprio contento ragazzino è stato
mi è piaciuto un sacco ma tantissimo e
il gatto non ci credo il gatto alla fine
si che era un mio amico perché non penso
fosse la strega invece no la storia
della straniera molto più intricata
finissimo bravo bello mi è piaciuto
veramente sincero quindi ragazzi spero
che mi sia piaciuto the witch house
finisce qua non ha certo bisogno mi
piace anche messo seguito tedeschi siano
fattori si chiede che non ci vediamo un
po seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]